[Music]
haley
is with us haley's in greeley colorado
hi hayley how are you
doing well how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um well i called a couple of weeks ago
and spoke to
john and anthony and they helped walk um
my husband and i through the first step
of our journey and got us set up with
ramsey plus wow since then we have
figured out our why and set up our every
dollar budget
and due to employment and income issues
during the height of covid
we had to surrender two vehicles back in
july
ouch yeah
we received the first vehicles deficit
letter
and our original creditor offered to
settle on monthly payments for 12 months
in order to not send our account to a
collection agency
please don't do it did you do that if we
did you do that confirm did you do that
don't do that
pain i don't care if they show your
collection
who cares if you went to a collection
agency you're in repo'd
okay let them sit you got no money
they can just sit the longer they sit
the more pliable and soft they become
okay i see i was thinking that there's a
possibility we could settle for a lesser
amount if we saved up some cash over the
next year or so
yep um and just filtered through our
debt snowballs
and okay yeah what did they declare the
deficit to be
the first vehicle is 15 000
and they don't know the other one yet
okay you can settle that for about 20
cents
on the dollar so i'm gonna offer them
about three i'm gonna offer them about
three grand
on the anniversary of the repo okay
about july just let those people sit
let me tell you what they usually get
let me tell how much of deficit they
usually collect
the typical deficit collection is zero
most people that go through a repo and
get a fifteen thousand dollar bill file
chapter seven bankruptcy
they get zero most of the time so if you
just keep them on the hook and keep
messing with them and
offer them you know tell them i don't
have any money i got two thousand
dollars if you want to take that
as settlement in full but i can't give
you fifteen thousand that's not even
gonna come close we're not gonna do
you know that's a joke well you're a
joke no i know i'm a joke you took my
car i'm already a joke so ha ha
call me in july you know hang up the
phone is there any possibility they
could
garnish our wages for it only after they
sue you
okay and they won't get around to that
for another two years
right because you know what happens when
they garnish you people's wages
you know what happens when they garnish
people's wages on a repo deficit
they file chapter seven bankruptcy and
they get zero
all righty so here's the thing this
matters to you
one thousand times more than it matters
to anyone else on this planet
including those people you owe money to
you're treating it as if
those are real humans on the other side
of this equation
it's corporate america they don't give a
crap
they're running statistical
probabilities on whether they're going
to get any money out of you at all
and the statistical probability is
they're going to get zero so if you just
keep talking to them
hold them out and offer them two
thousand three thousand dollars cash is
settlement in full
you're going to settle this between two
and five thousand dollars somewhere in
there
by july and a lump sum and beca
and they're gonna feel really blessed
because most of the time they get zero
okay so just don't you're trying to
they're still a part of you that's
uh you're an honorable good person and
under the heading of doing the right
thing
you're still trying to think like they
have feelings on the other side they
don't have feelings over there
does that make sense yes sir
yeah like if i owed you the money if you
owe me the money i might have feelings
about it
or you owed me the money you know or
vice versa whichever way
we would you two human beings we'd have
feelings about it
but these aren't humans these are just
collectors
right so they're just you're just a a
widget in a factory
going down the uh going down the uh
the conveyor belt
and you know as soon as they hang up
with you they're sitting in a cubicle
with a headset on and they call somebody
else and harass them
okay thank you okay so just chill
yeah just settle it lump sum settled in
full that's the thing